gegen den flickenteppich und für mehr
einheitlichkeit in der korona krise will
die kanzlerin mehr macht für den bund
viele länder sind dagegen
kaufverhandlungen über russischen
impfstoff gesundheitsminister sparen
kündigt direkte gespräche mit den
herstellern von sputnik wie an
ohne die eu die waffengesetze in den usa
sollen verschärft werden
präsident biden will damit ein
wahlversprechen einlösen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
der 19 uhr nachrichten zusammen mit dem
sport und norbert lehmann ein
sogenannter familie bevor wir in die
debatte über lockdown oder nicht
lockdown einsteigen erstmal das positive
seit hausärzte und ärztinnen mit schuhen
hat es impfen fahrt aufgenommen
656.000 menschen bekamen gestern in
deutschland ihren antiken apex mehr als
doppelt so viele wie am tag zuvor
davon unabhängig kämpft die
bundesregierung jetzt um mehr
kompetenzen damit sie die von cdu-chef
laschet vorgeschlagenen notbremse
durchsetzen kann
auch gegen die länder wenn er schafft es
schwelt eine debatte im land wer soll in
der pandemie das sagen haben
angela merkel hatte vor elf tagen
angedeutet was sie zu tun gedenkt wenn
die länder nicht die vereinbarte
notbremse ziehen
wenn das nicht der fall ist in sehr
absehbarer zeit dann muss ich überlegen
das ist mein amtszeit aus meine
verpflichtung wie kann man das
vielleicht auch bundeseinheitlich und
das vielleicht ich denke noch nach ich
bin noch nicht abschließend entschieden
aber eine möglichkeit ist daneben auch
das infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal
anzupacken
seitdem wird hinter den kulissen
verhandelt unterstützung bekommt merkel
aus der unionsfraktion
52 abgeordnete haben sich bislang für
mehr kompetenzen des bundes
ausgesprochen
wir sind in einer schwierigen
hoffentlich letzten phase der pandemie
brauchen jetzt konsequentes vorgehen
und da geht es uns darum auch deutlich
zu machen dass wir bundeseinheitlich
sehr konsequent weiter miteinander
handeln und das ist ein bisschen
verloren gegangen werden glaubt dass
wenn die bundeskanzlerin nur richtig
durchgreifen kann besiegen wir die
pandemie der irrt ich weiß auch nicht ob
frau merkel dann gegebenenfalls panzer
ins saarland schicken will
das alles ist einigermaßen absurd aus
meiner sicht wenn es
nachbesserungsbedarf ist dann soll man
das konkret vorschlagen
gegen bundesweite regelungen und gegen
einen harten lockdown sind vor allem die
spd regierten
bundesländer ich kann nur appellieren
dass wir uns verständigen gemeinsame
vorfeld der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nicht mit ideen sondern mit einem klaren
vorgehen
aus meiner sicht brauchen wir gar nicht
unbedingt neue beschlüsse wir haben
nämlich sehr klare beschlüsse sondern es
geht vor allem darum dass wir diese
beschlüsse gemeinsam umsetzen und so
wird auch ungewisse ob sich bund und
länder tatsächlich montag treffen
das bräuchte dafür mehr gemeinsamkeit
darin sind sich alle einig ja ob sich am
montag also tatsächlich bund und länder
zusammensetzen das scheint im moment gar
nicht so sicher zu sein jack unter der
manager oder wie ist der stand der dinge
ja das wort das wir heute aus bund
länder kreisen am häufigsten gehört
haben zur beschreibung der lage ist
unübersichtlich man hatte sich ja
eigentlich vorgenommen dass man sich
diesmal mit mehr vorlauf zusammensetzt
und gemeinsam über ideen und vorschläge
beugt so dass man diese dann am ende in
der sitzung am montag nur noch zügig
gemeinsam abstimmen kann
und es war auch noch der wunsch im raum
dass man das ganze in präsenz macht dass
er sich physisch hier zusammensetzt in
berlin im kanzleramt damit nicht mehr so
viel über videokonferenzen nach draußen
dringt all diese fragen scheinen
momentan noch offen zu sein es gibt
aktuell so hören wir noch keine
einladung zur sitzung es gibt auch noch
keine vorlage über die man diskutieren
könnte und wie man sich nun trifft
videokonferenz- oder präsenz das ist
auch noch offen und damit steht das
ganze treffen aktuell tatsächlich auf
der kippe von volker bouffier zum
beispiel weiß man dass er nach der
letzten sitzung gesagt hat also ich
komme beim nächsten mal nur wenn wir uns
physisch gemeinsam an einem ort treffen
markus söder hat ja gestern schon ins
gespräch gebracht wenn es keine klare
linie gibt dann sollte man das ganze
vielleicht eher verschieben diese klare
linie ist momentan auch noch nicht in
sicht und jetzt muss man schauen wie
sich das entwickelt die guten vorsätze
scheinen nicht ganz so gut umgesetzt zu
werden wie man sich das vorgenommen hat
noch ist es nicht ausgeschlossen dass
man alle fragen ausräumen kann bis
montag aber die zeit wird zunehmend
knapper tatsächlich unübersichtlich
vielen dank herr konnte energy nach
berlin schauen wir auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen in deutschland sie sind
weiter nur bedingt aussagekräftig da
während der osterferien weniger getestet
und gemeldet wird
das robert koch institut registrierte
20.000
407 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden wurden 306 neue todesfälle
verzeichnet weiter steigend sind die
zahlen der intensivbetten die mit corona
patienten belegt sind 4474 sind es jetzt
das sind 7 145 mehr als noch vor einer
woche im kampf gegen die pandemie setzt
die bundesregierung auf massenhaftes
testen
auch die betriebe sollen dabei mitmachen
notfalls per testpflicht dagegen laufen
die unternehmerverbände sturm assistiert
vom bundeswirtschaftsminister viele
betriebe beklagen beschaffungs probleme
und die hohen kosten stefan schlosser
mittlerweile ist es fast schon routine
seit vier wochen werden die rund 80
mitarbeiter dieser wiesbadener
haustechnik firma getestet zwei mal
wöchentlich auch der chef für ihn ein
wichtiges plus an sicherheit
die kunden gegenüber hin in die privaten
räume und haben auch direkt kontakt mit
den menschen und und durchsagen und
unsere leute sind somit getestet und
können keine infektion weiter dran
mehr als 4000 euro in der woche kosten
tests und masken ein hoher betrag testen
findet jochen ruß natürlich auch gut
eine pflicht nicht unbedingt er betreibt
zwei modehäuser mit insgesamt 40
angestellten und ist auch präsident des
hessischen handelsverbands nur drei
wochen durfte er in diesem jahr öffnen
wenn es eine pflicht wäre muss es auf
jeden fall mitfinanziert werden es kann
nicht sein dass der gebeutelte handel
dass die gebäudewirtschaft oder auch
später raus gastronomie jetzt noch
zusätzlich mit kosten belegt werden
für eine testpflicht einer umfrage der
dihk zufolge testet bereits rund die
hälfte aller unternehmen freiwillig oder
will es demnächst von denen die nicht
testen haben viele geschlossen oder
arbeiten komplett im home office statt
mehr bürokratie brauche es endlich
planungssicherheit fordern
wirtschaftsverbände von den
ministerpräsidentin einheitliche sprache
gesprochen gelöst unentschieden werden
dass ich das ganz wesentliche es darf
nicht passieren dass es einige sagt wird
und dass andere getan wird wie eine
testpflicht überhaupt kontrolliert
werden könnte ist
nicht klar aktionismus dass jochen roth
für ihn zählt nur endlich wieder öffnen
zu dürfen um für deutschland den
impfstoff sputnik wie zu beschaffen will
die bundesregierung direkt mit dem
russischen hersteller verhandeln ohne
die eu kommission einzubeziehen
das hat gesundheitsminister sparen
mitgeteilt eingesetzt werden soll
sputnik wie allerdings erst nach der
zulassung durch europas
arzneimittelagentur alleingänge haben
auch bayern und mecklenburg vorpommern
angekündigt auto an kurschilgen mit den
hintergründen
hier wird seit anfang märz geprüft wie
spritzig wie wirkt ob und wann die eu
arzneimittelbehörde ema den impfstoff zu
lassen wird ist unklar
ohne zulassung darf das vakzin in
deutschland nicht verimpft werden
das kann aber noch wochen oder monate
dauern weil nicht ganz klar ist ob
moskau alle relevanten daten an die
email geliefert hat die ständige
impfkommission ist aber optimistisch und
wenn die der impfstoff geprüft und
zugelassen
die sputnik initiative wird auch von den
bundesländern begrüßt einigen geht es
aber offenbar nicht schnell genug bayern
presse bereits gestern vor und sicherte
sich 2,5 millionen impfdosen und das
kommt nicht überall gut an dass das
ausgerechnet derjenige kollege macht der
ansonsten mit markigen worten immer ein
betont einheitliches verhalten in der
planie bekämpfung fordert das spricht
doch für sich obwohl der bund eigentlich
zuständig ist für die beschaffung von
impfstoff will auch mecklenburg
vorpommern nicht auf den
bundesgesundheitsminister warten sondern
lieber selbst in moskau bestellen
wir wollen eine million impfdosen von
sputnik option ihren im falle der
zulassung durch die emea die dann auch
zu kaufen
deutschland will sich mit sputnik wie
eine zusätzliche option sichern für ein
höheres im tempo doch alles hängt davon
ab ob und wann der russische impfstoff
in der eu zugelassen wird
brasiliens präsident ball so nahe hat
sein interesse an sputnik w
diese woche gleich direkt mit dem
russischen präsidenten putin besprochen
ball so nahe steht unter druck die
impfungen im land kommen nur schleppend
voran
erst 8,4 prozent der bevölkerung haben
zumindest eine dosis erhalten
auf der anderen seite schießt die zahl
der toten steil nach oben
zuletzt wurden rund 4000 tote pro tag
gemeldet
christoph röck hat berichtet selbst den
toten lässt das virus keine ruhe
auf ihrem friedhof im norden von sao
paulo müssen sie raus aus ihren gräbern
um platz zu schaffen für jene die
täglich zu tausenden sterben die trauer
untermalt den klang der schaufeln wenn
die letzten toten des tages eilig
begraben werden das sterben in brasilien
zieht immer weitere kreise
wir durchleben eine große traurigkeit
nicht nur unsere familie sondern
tausende familien in brasilien und auf
der ganzen welt
im märz starben doppelt so viele
menschen wie im februar und die zahlen
rasen weiter nach oben
das gesundheitswesen ist längst
überlastet die impfkampagne gerät immer
wieder ins stocken während sich täglich
menschenmassen in überfüllten
verkehrsmitteln auf zur arbeit machen
weil sie müssen wenn ich nicht arbeite
habe ich nichts zu essen ich kann die
miete nicht bezahlen ich muss meine
familie ernähren und dafür in diesen
dreckigen bus in mein leben riskieren
präsident portion euro der das virus von
anfang an verharmlost hat wehrt sich
weiter gegen jede form von shutdown
maßnahmen wie sie wissenschaftler
fordern
das argument gegen einen schatten ist
dass er die wirtschaft weiter schwächen
würde schon jetzt leiden immer mehr
brasilianer unter armut und sogar hunger
doch wenn sich das virus weiter
ungebremst verbreiten kann wächst
gleichzeitig die gefahr dass immer neue
gefährlichere varianten entstehen können
und diese zu fürchten wissenschaftler
könnten früher oder später die wirkung
von impfstoffen umgehen das scheitern
brasiliens eine angemessene antwort auf
corona zu finden könnte so zu einem
problem werden für die ganze welt
us-präsident beiden scheint entschlossen
sich mit der mächtigen waffenlobby
anzulegen
als erstes will er gegen sogenannte
geister waffen vorgehen deren bauteile
online bestellen
oder in 3d druckern hergestellt werden
können für beiden erklärtermaßen nur ein
anfang im kampf für ein strengeres
waffenrecht jenes drums berichtet eine
zeremonie im rosengarten des weißen
hauses präsident biden will zeigen es
ist ihm ernst mit schärferer
waffenkontrollen mit präsidial erlassen
will er das umkämpfte thema angehen für
eine gesetzgeberische lösung hat er
bislang keine mehrheit
waffengewalt ist in diesem land eine
epidemie international eine
feindlichkeit es ist herrgott nochmal
eine epidemie es muss aufhören dass
starb beiden steht unter druck hatten
doch erneut massen schießereien in
georgia und colorado die nation aktuell
erschüttert parteifreunde drängen auf
eine umsetzung seiner wahlversprechen
strengere regeln will beiden zunächst
für sogenannte ghost ganz geister waffen
ohne seriennummer die als bausätze
online bestellt und zusammengebaut
werden können kriminelle terroristen
jeder kann solche bausätze kaufen ich
will dass sie wie waffen gewertet werden
dass erfordert dass die produzenten
dieser bausätze die hauptteile mit
seriennummern versehen
außerdem will beiden den besitz von
zusatz griffen einschränken mit denen
pistolen die zielgenauigkeit eines
gewehrs bekommen auch soll es einen
umfassenden bericht zum waffenhandel
geben denn erst nach 20 jahren diese
erlasse können nur ein erster ein
kleiner schritt sein darüber hinaus will
präsident biden kriegs artige waffen wie
sturmgewehre verbieten und waffenkäufer
strenger überprüfen das geht aber nur
über eingesetzt und es ist zweifelhaft
dass beiden ein solches gesetz durch den
senat bekommt solange die us verfassung
das recht auf waffenbesitz garantiert
und die waffenlobby im land stark ist
wird es schwer
grundlegende änderungen durchzusetzen
israel hat der sechs millionen jüdischen
opfer des holocaust gedacht
landesweit hielten die menschen am
vormittag zwei minuten inne
begonnen hatten die feierlichkeiten
bereits gestern abend in der
gedenkstätte jad vaschem
zur erinnerung an die opfer der
nationalsozialisten entzündeten
holocaust-überlebende sechsfachen die
ausgrenzung von sinti und roma hat sich
durch die korona pandemie in vielen
ländern europas verstärkt so der
zentralrat deutscher sinti und roma in
einer erklärung zum fünfzigsten welt
rheuma tag der heute begangen wird
im zdf sagte der zentralrats vorsitzende
romani rose wieder suchten nationalisten
die ursache für die korona krise bei
minderheiten wie sinti und roma aus
nordirland erreichen uns bilder die an
jene schlimme zeit erinnern als mehr als
3000 menschen in einem blutigen konflikt
ihr leben verloren
die vierte nacht in folge ist es dauert
zu schweren krawallen gekommen zwischen
pro-britischen unionisten und anhängern
eines vereinigten irlands der brh exit
hat eine ohnehin wacklige politische
balance ins wanken gebracht diana
zimmermann
es gab nie einen guten krieg oder einen
schlechten frieden so steht es auf dem
tor des eines der protestantischen
viertel belfasts vor dem gegenüber
liegenden katholischen trend jeden abend
auch 23 jahre nach dem
karfreitagsabkommen werden diese tore
immer noch geschlossen
doch in den letzten tagen warfen
jugendliche brandsätze über die
absperrungen brachen sie gewaltsam auf
attackierten polizeiwagen und verletzten
mehr als 50 polizisten
der britische und der irische premier
haben zum dialog aufgerufen die
regierung nordirlands kam zu einer
krisensitzung zusammen
moskau die gewalt muss aufhören so wie
sie in der vergangenheit falsch war und
nicht gerechtfertigt werden konnte ist
sie es heute auch
hauptgrund für die wieder aufflammenden
spannungen zwischen den
bevölkerungsgruppen ist der brh exit die
meisten unionisten haben für den bhc
rexit gestimmt aber sie wollten nicht
dass nordirland anders behandelt wird
als der rest des königreichs das
austritts abkommen schafft aber sehr
wohl eine solche sonderbehandlung vor
allem dadurch dass nun eine handelt
grenze in der irischen see entstanden
ist an der produkte aus großbritannien
kontrolliert werden die protestantischen
unionisten befürchten dass
handelshemmnisse zwischen nordirland und
großbritannien nordirland noch enger mit
der republik irland verknüpfen und
irgendwann zu einer vereinigung führen
könnten
das wollen sie die anhänger des
königreichs unbedingt verhindern
gute nachrichten aus norwegen der in
seenot geratene frachter ist keine
gefahr mehr für die umwelt
er wurde in einen hafen an der
norwegischen westküste geschleppt das
112 meter lange schiff war
manövrierunfähig nachdem die ladung bei
stürmischen wetter verrutscht war
die besatzung wurde per hubschrauber
gerettet der frachter mit 350 tonnen
schweröl und 50 tonnen diesel an bord
bedrohte sensible naturgebiete zum sport
und zur niederlage der bayern gestern
abend in der champions weit zu drei zu
hause verloren gegen paris langsame
schmerzhaft und vor allem ärgerlich
münchen die bessere mannschaft fünfmal
so viele torschüsse wie pc
der titelverteidiger steht vor dem
viertelfinal-rückspiel am dienstag mit
dem rücken zur wand
selbst der hochmotivierte antreiber
thomas müller konnte den ausfall des
verletzten bayern torjägers lewandowski
nicht vergessen machen
zwar gelang ihm vor den augen des
bundestrainers für die optisch
überlegenen bayern nach einer stunde der
2 2 ausgleich und das nach frühem 0
2-rückstand der mann des spiels aber
hieß mbp der wegweisende führungstreffer
war diesem in der dritten spielminute
gelungen durch die beine von manuel
neuer und kurz nach müll als ausgleicht
düpierte empathie die bayern abwehr zum
3 2 siegtreffer
dennoch glaubt der bayern trainers
weiter corp wir werden alles dafür tun
und jeder einzelne spieler der auf dem
feld ist und er dann eingewechselt wird
das wir dass wir dieses spiel noch mal
drehen
das dürfte schwer werden und in der
letzten viertelfinal begegnung des dfb
pokals hat sich gestern abend werder
bremen gegen zweitligist jahn regensburg
knapp durchgesetzt
das einzige und damit entscheidende tor
des spiels fiel in der 52 minute durch
julio sattel der bundesliga 13 trifft im
halbfinale am 30
april im eigenen stadion auf rb leipzig
eishockey nationalspieler leon
dreiseitel hat mit seinem fünften
hattrick in der nfl erneut seine
weltklasse bewiesen und war beim 4 2
seiner edmonton oilers bei den ottawa
senators wieder einmal der matchwinner
dreiseitel gelingen drei treffer von
denen der zum 2 2 1 länger in erinnerung
bleiben wird ein schlagschuss bei dem er
hinter der torlinie steht deutschlands
sportler des jahres mit einem tor des
jahres aus denkbar spitzem winkel auch
als vorlagengeber glänzte der gebürtige
kölner das verständnis mit kondomen eck
david ist ein blindes der schlängelt
sich durch zum 3 2 die beiden anderen
dreiseitel tore er standard knallharter
schuss zum 1 0
wohl überlegt das 4 2 ins verlassene tor
der autor stan ockers dreiseitel treffer
lassen edmonton für die playoffs planen
das was vom sportplatz zum schluss
zeigen wir ihnen noch wie man auch mit
feuer ganze ernten retten kann
im burgund illuminieren zigtausende
flammen die nächtlichen weinberge ein
lichtermeer bis in die ferne düsterer
hintergrund tiefkühltemperaturen
bedrohen die reben winzer kämpfen so
gegen den frost
es gilt den chablis zu retten einen
trockenen tropfen mit bauchigen aromen
möge es gelingen beim wetter ganz
unterschiedliche aussichten regner wir
schon kühl für die einen sonnig und mild
für die anderen mehr gleich von katja
horneffer so viel von uns danke für ihr
interesse
claus kleber spricht um 21 uhr 45 im
heute journal mit wolfgang schäuble und
wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder
mit dabei sind um 19 uhr einen schönen
abend noch tschüss
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren da kommt
wieder mal eine kleine kaltfront heran
und die zieht über die nordsee und
erreicht bis morgen abend das emsland
und usedom und mit dieser kaltfront
kommen auch viele wolken mit das macht
sie schon heute nacht bemerkbar
so kann es hier noch fließt dann schon
etwas regnen im süden ist es dagegen
klar unter den dichteren wolken im
nordwesten bleibt die nacht recht bild
mit 5 bis 1 grad im süden dagegen gc
frost von minus 1 bis minus sieben grad
und auch obwohl es in süddeutschland so
wahnsinnig kalt wird in der nacht
katapultieren sich da morgen die
temperaturen auf frühlingshafte 13 bis
19 grad im norden bleibt es bei 8 bis 13
grad kinder da sind einfach viele wolken
unterwegs die auch regen mitbringen hier
zwischen rügen und norderney
etwa südlich der nördlichen
mittelgebirge scheint morgen aber häufig
die sonne
bei südwestwind der samstag bringt uns
dann viel regen im westen deutschlands
bei 8 bis 17 grad und der sonntag gibt
dann eine richtige wetter zweiteilung
her
im nordwesten ist es kühl mit viel regen
steigen die werte nur auf sechs grad und
im südosten strahlt die sonne und die
temperaturen klettern auf 20 grad in der
neuen woche kommt die kühle wirft auch
am alpenrand an
schön auch noch